I just want to say thank you
for all the love and support that you
guys have sent to me and my family this
time
Allison Holger posts her first video
message to fans following her husband
Steven twitch boss's tragic death it has
been very challenging and emotional
but you guys have brought
so much hope and inspiration to us by
sharing stories and memories and moments
and different ways that Stephen impacted
your life and it's brought us so much
hope and inspiration on Saturday Allison
posted that clip to Instagram thanking
fans for their love and support
I will always be there for you guys and
I appreciate you guys being there for us
at this moment
it really
it goes a really far away for us so
thank you and I hope you guys remember
how special you are and how much of an
impact you make
around the world and continue to move
from there
we love you guys
twitch died by suicide in December and
Allison's emotional post comes a week
after 500 friends and family members
gathered in La for his celebration of
life Ellen DeGeneres Portia de Rossi and
Lonnie Love were in attendance as well
as many of twitch's friends from So You
Think You Can Dance and The Ellen
Degeneres Show Stephen twitch was such a
significant part of the dance Community
but then he had this amazing ability to
go way beyond that and he just lit up
every room and he was so positive I
think anyone who's ever met twitch will
say that he is the nicest most caring
most
you know present person and and really
wants to make everyone feel better
shortly after Allison posted her video
message Ellen showed her support in the
comments writing his light is still so
bright so is yours he was someone that
was just beautiful and he lived his life
from Love and he made you feel a certain
way Allison and twitch have two children
together six-year-old son Maddox and
three-year-old daughter ziya twitch is
also dad to Allison's 14 year old
daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people now Allison says they will honor
his legacy by spreading light and
happiness
my family and I have always said that we
wanted to make sure that our purpose was
lived out by bringing joy to people it's
going to feel a little bit different
but we know that that's our purpose and
we'll still do that to this day
and I hope that we can remember
the feeling that he gave us and remember
that we can still move from there